eh bien c'est raté dans son album parle
d'amour évidemment l'amour c'est oh
l'amour c'est l'amour c'est l'amour quoi
voilà voilà pour 20% des français
l'effet des français pensent avec les
blues en faisant l'amour d'un bon sens
c'est beaucoup quand même
pourtant ça change quelque chose au dos
par exemple vers l'amo et dégagement
jamais noblette c'est samantha une
petite blague c'est une date de
gainsbourg télé quand on fait l'amour
pour un garçon le problème c'est c'est
de se dire mais il faut que je tienne un
peu quoi il faut que ses ébats dans ces
cas là vous pensez vous êtes au
restaurant donc vous ouvrez la carte
dababech pourrait même entrer je
prendrais bien après un petit plat et
puis après je prendrai bien deuxième
petit plat et un dessert n'en fût ce
qu'à fait bien ça dure du temps voilà et
nager la chute
la chute à l'arrivée connard si vous
voulez aller à nos spagnou l'édition
mais venu comme ça comme ça j'ai livré
un tableau derrière moi 2 2 quand ça va
alors il ya des chroniqueurs parlent pas
remis par me bats parmi vous c'est vous
en faites un qui pensent en majorité non
qu'ils font l'amour
vous pensez à quoi par exemple quand je
fais l'amour oui moi le mien je peux
penser à rien d'autre que lui à une
belle génération
ben oui ah ouais on pensait jamais aux
travaux c'est ça se passe très bien donc
je n'ai pas le temps de penser à aux
impôts
à votre avis alors qui peut penser à
bout de quelqu'un qui n'a jamais fait
l'amour certaines modano qui va donc à
bouder en besoin d'amour s'est tordu et
rachel bourlier dire que la nadal patte
de d'une star hollywoodienne trouve
acquiesça correspond pas je regarde
l'histoire tpm t était invité dans
l'émission chambre as good heart est pas
un camarade d'ailleurs et peu de temps
après l'émission je suis avec mon
camarade de jeu et là je sais pas
pourquoi
[Rires]
je faisais que de penser à bouder et
dont je me crois un fou rire vous cache
pas que la ce a coupé sa libido il m'en
a énormément voulu je pourrai pas lui
dire que je voyais bouder quand il me
faisait l'amour il - ajout du monde
parce que voilà c'est alors à votre avis
les équipes à qui pense à son chat à
daniel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pat shanhan guy vous avez un chat
j'ai pas d'animaux chila alors mon chat
c'est nouveau à 100% sur cet instant
suspendu et peut dire tout mignon
présent j'ai vu un fichier non des gens
suspendait comme ça oui c'est un autre
registre alors qu'ils arc à 800 mhz
alors accueilli 6 ans et francesca
pourquoi jean calas terrain bordé oui
c'est moi parce que c'est drôle parce
qu'une fois j'ai été tellement mauvais
que j'ai fait moins de 10 secondes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est drôle donc suspendu trois mois
c'est mauvais présage 1 6 et 2 ans
c'est moi c'est mon angoisse de péter
pendant la dernière
c'est un peu difficile et ce pirate
heures avant à ça c'est un hygiéniste et
bernard à autun tordu savez savez quoi
passer à la maison soit voilà donc je
passe l'aspirateur à la et j'y pense
quand je le fais aussi je me dis est ce
que j'ai bien tout nettoyer des impôts
je sais que ça l'angoissé zone est à la
base j'avais dit bernard montiel on a
dix membres casse
non c'est à mes impôts pour les faire
bien mal à très bien merci super g qui a
peut être qui sa voisine âgée et amélie
nom à jamais home est sorti à défaut
faire comme gilles de faire moins de 10
secondes j'essaie de penser à l'histoire
on est un peu plus long dans la durée
quand on travaille bien et la monnaie
pour moi
qui savait témoin l'aurait marqué à mais
ça mais ça m'est déjà arrivé apache
honnêtement c'est déjà arrivé à
plusieurs personnes
oui mais bien non alors moi je pense à
rien merci beaucoup
sachez que 20 % des français pensent eux
au travail ça les perturbe ça les
perturbe sebhaoui se confond bah oui non
pas comme vous le travail